so I rarely ever recommend divorce but
I'll tell you why it's actually
important that men divorce or at least
separate from these women I'm assuming
there's no abuse cheating on his side
you you teach your daughter there's no
consequences for this type of now
kids aren't stupid and a lot of times
they spend more time with the woman than
you do so by accepting this Behavior
you're basically teaching your daughter
that this shit's okay
um and what kind of you know what kind
of mother is she If instead of you know
catering to her daughter she's effing
some guy in a hotel
um and it's really it you know I I some
guys probably will would stick it out
for the kids for a couple years you know
I think that's to the discretion of the
guy I mean he knows the daughter better
but uh this is sad